let's try the caro-kann all right d5 and
now mainline I really want to avoid the
mainland ah ha ha the black bar right no
thanks I don't want to deal with that
okay
oh I'm already stuck do I play Bishop f5
and run into this g4 9 h3 Knight f4
stuff I don't know maybe I will maybe I
won't and maybe I definitely will cuz I
lost my opportunity if I really want to
do that forget about it it's not
happening so what do I do
hmm alright I make my bishop look a
little silly and my opponent is going
fast as usual maybe I could try to get
him off the board though let's try like
this they take I think that would help
me out this night isn't doing anything
on b8 and it's not out of play by being
on 86 coming to play get to that d5
square pretty quick for a second there I
actually considered moving my knight
let's not blunder a piece here don't you
dare
all right well
let's take
let's throw a question that night see
what wants to do also pressure on the
bishop if the knight is captured how to
recapture a few ways this seems best
okay why would this seem best it's a bit
awkward to have this pawn on c6 I would
much rather have my knight here the
structure becomes a bit more symmetrical
hmm however after all that what am i
afraid of if I take with the pawn might
there be a quick f4 f5 stuff
hmm if I take what this pond right there
being Knight G 3 to f5 might I be stuck
for a good move here I my opponent is
fully developed and well actually taken
with the Queen it's threatening both
pawns this is uh this is scary this is
scary
I don't know if I really want to take
this pot if right here working here if I
take this and it's threatened if I take
this I drop my pawn over here this is
scary I think I want to do this and stir
up some stroke some struggle turn stir
up some struggle yep that's what I'd
like to say Queen takes pawn Knight c3 I
give a check the King runs here the rook
eventually hits my queen back although
although although I think I have
something for it I'm gonna grab the pawn
and hopefully force white to show me
this is the show-me move show me the
compensation actually I already know
where the compensation is but let's put
the question to white let's chase the
King elsewhere force the knight back
okay it went back let's trade Queens now
could we just trade Queens all I want to
do is trade Queens can we do that please
it's not good friend Frank be gamba is
not gonna make it
so easy on me I could feel it I could
feel it already there's not gonna be a
queen trade um yes sir that is a good
move and guess who has a lot of work to
do mean I need a lot of work because I
am under what am i under I am under
developed and this is really scary
how will light recapture okay
this is scary once again very scary very
very scary very very scary
I think Knight d7 to this square is
needed oh is this scary time or what Wow
oh man
Oh Mikey Castle wait a second I had that
move available the whole time why didn't
I consider castle right there I was
forgetting my Queen was defending my
bishop and oh okay I could do this it
could be challenged but it's still scary
about this about not here pawn push I
better just move how I just start moving
this is real scary h6 I might be needing
to play a real soon really soon very
soon but there bit really be a queen
trade that's a good move I like that
move okay my king has to play h7 there's
gonna be a rook hitting my queen real
soon really really soon Queen here
no Queen here I don't know what I want
to do my knight needs to play in the
game sometime rook g8 King h7 rook e1
Queen d7 or D 6 D 6 I'm gonna like I'm
d6 cuz no I'm not gonna like that
because Knight here and here there's so
much have to worry about and I don't
have good moves
how about Queen go home she might have
to go home she do good for your home oh
man yeah this is good compensation
without a doubt thankfully this bishop
is around to defend and let's do this
before it's too late I guess I still
have a clothesline this I'm not I could
care less about my seat pile at this
point I need to get developed
Oh what's up Oh what is going on with
that Queen move I don't understand it
am I missing something I have this one
available but I'm in no position to go
grabbing for material let's get some
pieces off could be here we get some
pieces off the board please
oh that Knights ready to kill me I could
do this this is is this sort of working
out huh I want to get in my rook here
and then is everything gonna be nice and
cozy I think I'm close to being cozy
please say it's gonna be okay night
right here wind stuff doesn't it I
better take here and then run away here
if I'd if I brought my other work over I
end up losing a rook oh man this is
scary 22 seconds Knight takes pawn is
available come on say it's gonna be okay
tell me it's okay oh I need to get
active and I'm not getting active my
knight needs to play the game is he
gonna play Oh what's the scoop whoa that
is a killer move right there my queen is
not happy with things
can I get active here I need some
activity 17 seconds is not enough I
could throw on a bishop check or
something I could get my knight on d5 in
that Bishop where's the rook activity is
this gonna hold some how could this hold
Queen here my knight might get hit I
might have to go to seed 3 whoa what's
going on with that movie my getting
mated get that Queen out of there oh
they missed that I'm not the Queen
I think they made me thought I had they
had um Bishop takes any or something I'm
on the clean stuff is falling now
oh it's crumbling crumbling it's a easy
to promote with there's just these
pieces remaining my phone is typing at
me they said that they messed up I think
there is at least a time when for my
opponent oh they're still playing in was
that a decoy I bet a decoy there okay
was being lured away to having my
attention John to the chat okay
I thought they're just resigned good
game good game man there's no way
there's no way right there I should have
won that one man where did the time go
it went to trying to figure out how I
got into this mess okay well that's what
I get for declining the gambit what's
the best reputation to a gambit who
knows who said that line best reputation
to a gambit is to accept it or something
like that oh I learned a thing or two on
this one that's for sure
I really was uncomfortable once it got
to this position right here right here
it's like no matter what way I
recaptured I was feeling pressure a lot
of it the F pawn push was good positions
opening up I'm underdeveloped there was
a good idea by my opponent my opponents
a good player and went with the good
plan no surprise there very good what
could okay so I think this is something
to avoid first off the moves that I'm
making to get to this point I think I
need to try to go with the bishop move I
need to try and get that out but I guess
I was too lazy to calculate the g4 h4
and Knight h3 f4 nonsense putting
pressure on my light squares basically
but I'll have to look into this vision
of f5 movie
a bit more because I did not like this
position at all just trying to get rid
of the light square bishop is okay
they're off but look at this one to two
moves away from being fully developed
but and I'm up upon but so what this
Queen move is excellent
definitely avoid Queen exchange f5 is
there so you already have a G file to
play with so where's the knock out here
that I'm pretty sure there should be a
knock out
what's the plan what's the correct plan
for my opponent I'm looking for it
because it really feels like there
should be something here I am NOT better
I'm up a pond but who cares who cares it
does not feel that way clean there rook
here I think this guy is the number one
priority I think if you get rid of my
dark square Bishop I start feeling a lot
of pain a lot of pain comes my way if
you get rid of that dark squared Bishop
hmm
let's see what's the plan here
okay my opponents are coming up with
night g6 pawn takes h5 takes g6 should
took with the H pawn and then attack the
H oh oh so we're going we're getting to
this fast forwarding all the way to this
point that night h6 move your oh now
that is interesting
mmm I could really be feeling the
pressure there you lit the other pawn
with check flush my King to the corner
and then rook here looking for tricky
stuff on this square I can't be 100%
sure but white is already down a piece
and if this is a capture to go with then
I will to break the baton breakthroughs
still on the g7 h6 structure I think
white will be needing to invest another
piece and maybe that's kind of pushing
it maybe haven't worked it all out but
I'm thinking even before there was that
night move there was maybe a better plan
to be running with can't be sure
by the way this is what I was trying to
say when time pressure if I had played a
routine rook to this square rook takes
Queen takes rook here and I have my
Queen s to move and then I lose my
Brooke that's so that wouldn't be so
great also right here I think I'm losing
material if you throw your knight back
to d2 or maybe not because that rook h4
it's a little bit scary to do but okay I
thought it was trapped where is the plan
though I don't know I'm not it's not
jumping right out to me
it's the scoop cuz these seem Oh quite
purposeful the moves that were played oh
this this Queen move was a bit weird to
me how about how about getting your
night out and then look into the e4
square yeah I'm not so sure about the
Queen move being necessary
I guess it was played to watch over this
pond but if this bishop isn't on the
board I think you have an f6 move or
something or maybe even possibilities to
throw me in a pin although I could be
getting out of it so okay it's
understandable then see why you would
maybe want to protect that I don't know
if there was just I guess identifying
strengths for black right here this guy
right here is an excellent defender and
I guess still an attacker so if there's
somehow way that you could be getting
rid of him
those would certainly be plans to
consider but maybe it's barely just
hanging on just barely it is even
material right back over here I don't
know if that was a mouse up or not but
probably right there definitely made me
work for it that Bishop move was
definitely caught me off guard right
there definitely caught me off guard Wow
okay good game